my dad was a wonderful actor he was a
really interesting actor never really
made it made it but actors knew who he
was and and just loved his work and he
was in everything for a long time
that guy right oh yeah yeah he's in this
always in the prestige oh he's in
needful things so he's in he's in all
these movies and all these games and
this voice like this yeah morgan shepard
here
and
we weren't very close when i was a kid
and then we became very very close when
he moved over here to do max headroom
and we sort of fix whatever problems we
have by working together
acting together directing together doing
all this crazy stuff we did over the
years and and so
any successful moment any happy moment
any sad moment i'm used to picking up
the phone he either lived downstairs for
me across the road from me
or down the road from me for the last
25 years so it's hard to go laurel
canyon together but i'm used to picking
up the phone and saying oh so blah blah
blah
and i don't have that do you still think
about it like i pick up my phone all the
time but
my dad was in serious distress by the
time that he passed and his passing was
such a relief i could feel it was such a
relief for him he was done at 86 i think
um
that i wouldn't have wished him an extra
day i wouldn't have wished him an extra
minute the selfish side of course i want
him around forever but to have to be a
person who studied history and had
stories and and pulled people together
and which people just loved him
um
to not have that in the last five six
months of his life very very quickly he
descended into
um
you know he just didn't get enough
oxygen blood to his brain he had some he
had some issues and problems and and
they all got worse and instead of being
able to have open heart surgery he ended
up passing before that was possible and
that this was like three years ago two
and a half years ago two years ago i
think yeah two or three years ago um it
escapes me it feels like yesterday and
sometimes it feels like 10 years ago but
it's not
it's not tragic there's nothing tragic
about it and when i think of my dad i
think of really positive things i think
of fun things
i think of things he said i you know i
just worked with timothy dalton for the
last couple of years i remember seeing
tim dalton there's a great picture of my
dad and tim dalton if you look it up
doing the romans of the mermaid
in england which i saw as a kid
my dad was playing caesar it was just
like but i that i know him from then and
i end up working with him later
and every time i see john reese davis
it's like please remind your father he's
far far older than i it would be
but um
he was connected to so many people but
never as a as a big star he was just
somebody that people liked and did i
mean he did gettysburg he narrated
gettysburg he's the first voice in
gettysburg
so you know
those are big shoes to fill right right
that was the whole thing did you feel
like that you're going to you didn't
absolutely absolutely not i refuse to be
an actor for that reason um
but i don't act like him
we've talked together i mean i'm more of
a guess a check of trained actor and
he's he was in peterborough's royal
shakespeare company so he did marisol on
broadway did all that all the great
stuff that ever existed he worked with
luther hagen he taught
the actors studio in new york he did all
this stuff so he's part of that era of
theater
but his transition into film was a tough
thing for him because he always wanted
to be an american and so when he finally
got over here to do
max headroom
he did max headroom here and then he did
gun smoke he did the last max headroom
the voice no he was uh he was blank reg
in max headroom really punk guy with the
six-wheel bus the radio station yeah so
he came over to do that he i think he
signed a gersh and then he was in the
last gunsmoke movie he's in so many
things they're just
fun and he reinvented himself again
again if what what it was like you know
i i started acting cause i did this play
and then it got big and stuff happened
and i remember the front page of the
calendar so i'm not an actor i'm a
musician my dad's an actor
and i just got like drama critic circle
award or something stupid so i was like
it was just one of those things where
i didn't want the path he had because i
didn't like you
like
watching the negatives of what our job
is when you see people that don't love
it
you